Isak your you have been through so much
with your with with bran you'd been it's
just such a can you just do us a favor
because the story arc for bran is one of
the most incredible I think in the in
the entire show
can you summarize for us his his arc his
story arc it sort of started off as this
happy-go-lucky kid and it's all looking
so looking great likes climbing walls
and then he sort of captures a bit of
incest yeah straight out the window
yeah there go the legs yeah and then
alright you know his family have now
left one heard laugh the other things he
could move on then his house gets burnt
down he has to leave Winterfell starts
having these weird dreams meet some
strange guy from his dreams who's never
met before who tells him to go north to
some tree cave he has to send his
brother off makes it up north are we
near the cave that's great then some
zombies come and kill everyone get in
the cave it's like right oK we've been
through the wars now we're safe and then
the entire army of the Dead come to the
cave yeah ho doors gone asked to leave
the cave meets his weird half zombie
uncle who's been missing for six seasons
yeah he then leaves them again and then
we find them at the wall very confused
and travursel it's a typical adolescence
I think
you